noch kurz ein Gedanke zur Einordnung
dessen was wir da gerade erlebt haben
wir haben lavrov den russischen
Außenminister gehört und gesehen und
vorher haben wir Putin gesehen wir da im
Kreise von Luftfahrt Angestellten saß
und einen Monolog gehalten hat und das
war natürlich völlig klar eine
Inszenierung das haben wir in den
letzten Tagen immer wieder erlebt er hat
an diesen langen Tischen Generäle
empfangene hat Teile seines Kabinetts
empfangen er hat Minister empfangen und
hat Ihnen im Prinzip
stellvertretend für das Publikum
Vorträge gehalten und diese Vorträge
waren natürlich für die russische
Öffentlichkeit gedacht und mit diesen
Inszenierungen versucht Putin immer
wieder klar zu machen dass er sozusagen
das Sagen hat dass er am Ruder ist und
die anderen im gefälligst zuzuhören
haben und da will gar keinen Zweifel
aufkommen lassen wer die Macht hat ich
begrüße jetzt im Studio Egon Rams
früheren Nato-General herzlich
willkommen guten Abend wenn sie sowas
wie eben sehen was denken sie dann über
Putin und seine Leute ja diese
Inszenierung wie sie gerade gesagt haben
ziehen sich ja durch die letzten Wochen
wie ein roter Faden auf gut deutsch
gesagt und ich stehe da manchmal vor der
Frage ob die Rationalität von Putin noch
richtig funktioniert und ob da noch
alles in Ordnung ist und ob er nicht nur
nach bestimmten Möglichkeiten und
Rechtfertigung sucht um seinen
Gedankengebäude an seine Bevölkerung
heranzutragen und damit letztendlich
einen Großteil dessen was wir würde ich
mal aus unserer Sicht sagen als Wahrheit
bezeichnen den Gegenüber zu verschleiern
und wenn man die Situation sieht die wir
in den letzten Wochen erlebt haben nimmt
er ja oftmals auch die schlechteste
Lösung die dann für ihn möglich ist oder
für andere möglich ist für ihn scheint
es die beste zu sein und da muss man
sich schon fragen ob das von der
Rationalität her noch eine vertretbare
Vorgehensweise ist
nun haben wir ja gerade die Situation
dass der ukrainische Präsident sich eine
Flugverbotszone wünscht über der Ukraine
die NATO aber nicht darauf eingehen will
und kann aus den Gründen die wir vorhin
ja schon erwähnt haben inwiefern kann
denn die NATO die Ukraine überhaupt noch
unterstützen
also die NATO selber kann die Ukraine
unmittelbar nicht unterstützen sondern
das kann bestenfalls dann auf
bilateralem Wege passieren durch das was
wir zurzeit erleben also Waffenlieferung
ich sage mal Waffen aller Art
die die ukrainische Streitkräfte
befähigen den Kampf gegen die russische
Streitkräfte ich sag mal mit einer
höheren Qualität oder besser zu führen
das reicht von Kommunikationsmitteln bis
zu Waffen und Munition Haubitzen oder
dergleichen Dinge mehr wie es Estland ja
gemacht hat und wo sich ja Deutschland
mit den beiden Lieferungen
unterschiedlicher
luftbodenluft Raketen und auch mit den
Panzerfäusten entsprechend beteiligt hat
mehr geht nicht alles was in irgendeiner
Form das soll die Forderung von selensky
über den über dem Territorium der
Ukraine stattfinden würde mit
nato-flugzeugen oder auch mit mit
Flugabwehrraketen oder dergleichen mehr
wäre dann der Weg in die Kriegspartei
für die NATO-Staaten und dann ist
praktisch Tür und Tor geöffnet für alles
Mögliche was Putin gerne erreichen
möchte
welche Rolle spielt denn diese frühere
nato-ukraine Karte von 1997 in diesem
Konflikt noch
ja die NATO war damals mit der Ukraine
ähnlich wie mit Russland mit der NATO
Russland Grundakte die entsprechende
Zusammenarbeit vereinbart die auch lange
weiter fortgesetzt worden ist eigentlich
jetzt bis zum Ausbruch der
Feindseligkeiten fortgesetzt worden ist
wir haben ukrainische Streitkräfte
ausgebildet insbesondere zwischen 2014
und ich sage mal diesem Jahr Anfang
diesen Jahres oder Ende letzten Jahres
ausgebildet auf hoher Führungsebene aber
auch ausgebildet beispielsweise in dem
gebraucht moderner Kommunikationsmittel
und ähnlicher Dinge mehr von daher ist
das schon eine echte Hilfe für die
Streitkräfte gewesen und ich glaube auch
man kann feststellen dass die
ukrainische Streitkräfte die ja wie
gelähmt waren im Jahre 2014 als die Krim
annektiert wurde in den letzten acht
Jahren eine Menge dazu gelernt haben nun
ist es auch so dass die Ukraine
natürlich von einem NATO-Beitritt träumt
was würden Sie sagen ist der jetzt durch
diesen Konflikt eher wahrscheinlicher
oder eher unwahrscheinlicher geworden
also ich würde sagen im Augenblick ist
er ja unwahrscheinlicher geworden also
wenn man mit einem Land welches in
Frieden lebt und nicht von jemandem
angegriffen wird wir haben Adresse
angegriffen wird eine solche Sache
vorbereiten will dann kann man das über
bestimmte Abkommen und einen membership
Action Plan machen zur Aufnahme dieses
Landes das macht jetzt im Augenblick
wohl im Land aktuell Krieg geführt
werden überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr und
ist auch praktisch in diesem Bereich
nicht mehr realisierbar
von der politischen Seite her muss man
darüber nachdenken ob die Entscheidung
die ja letztendlich 2008 schon mal
gefällt worden ist die Ukraine und
Georgien damals nicht in die NATO
aufzuleben
damals die richtige Entscheidung gewesen
ist wenn man diese Entwicklung verfolgt
muss man vielleicht sagen nein obwohl
man dann möglicherweise putinen bereits
weitaus früher gereizt hätte sich an
Coron Sanitär um sein eigenes Land herum
zu bauen hinter dem er sich dann
entsprechend sicherer gefühlt hätte ich
glaube er hätte das auch wenn wir das
früher begonnen hätten in der Form nicht
hingenommen